[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mecs du Paris comme une ville hyper
propre
vous avez fait un petit
versus réalité regarder regarder
regarder Paris et en regarder la réalité
[Applaudissements]
montrer les quais regarder les quais
Paris voilà Paris Paris
là ma chérie ça va toi sinon
ils
sont en train de chercher c'est pas du
tout ça et voilà il y avait en fait il
n'y a aucun d'embouteillage au tu vas
bien
est-ce que vous savez et en fait il
pense à toi parce que il y a trop de
monde c'est complètement con c'est comme
ça et puis c'est très beau tout ça mais
c'est un prix
mais alors de façon de trouver toutes
les capitales qu'ils ont dépensé de
l'argent on en récupérer autant plus
longtemps
et surtout pendant au moins les gens qui
passe à la télé
il y a plein de choses que je vois la
grandeur de la France est la plus belle
[Applaudissements]
parce que
j'ai
des événements dans le monde entier
ça va être un bordel que tu connais aux
JO
[Applaudissements]
mais tu crois qu'on a attendu vendre
Paris pour les JO
[Rires]
il y a une ville qui est sorti indemne
de bien sûr
et tu verras quand tu seras dans ta
porte bloquée avec l'essence à 14
minutes
ok je serai derrière ta belle
tu me verras pas sur des mycoses
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon demain
dans la gueule
c'est
juste que
ok on
fait une émission
Tony Yoka
on n'est pas près d'ici
construction
Fabien sur
deezer
[Applaudissements]
Porsche